[MUSIC PLAYING]
PUSHKAR SHARMA: Welcome
to Cloud on Air.
There are live webinars from
Google Cloud every Tuesday.
My name is Pushkar Sharma.
I'm a product manager
in Google Cloud IoT.
Today we'll be talking
about Cloud IoT,
and talking about the
business use case,
and how it applies to IoT all
the way from Edge to the cloud.
You can ask questions anytime.
There are Googlers on standby.
And we'll be taking
those questions
at the end of the presentation.
But let's get started.
So today, first we'll start
off with measuring the business
outcomes with IoT.
Then we'll talk about the Cloud
IoT, in general, how we see it.
Then we'll talk about our new
offerings, Cloud IoT Edge,
and Edge TPU.
And then we'll move on to talk
about security and Cloud IoT
provisioning.
So let's talk about
business outcomes with IoT.
So there was a survey
done by McKinsey.
And it turns out that
84% of the companies
were stuck in pilot
phase for over a year,
and at 28% for over two years.
And about 30% of
these pilots only
could make it to the scale.
So about 70% of
these pilots never
made it to the production.
So what's really going on?
I mean, we call this
as a pilot purgatory.
So essentially what's going
on is you started with pilots,
and then you never
have success with it.
So what are the key success
metrics which we found?
It comes down to really
the business alignment.
Are you aligned with
your senior executives?
Do you have support?
Is there a strong business
case or vision and how
it will impact the business?
Or is there internal
alignment in how
do we execute, and a long
term perspective on that?
So really, it comes
down to an ROI.
If you can establish
ROI, you can easily
get these alignments.
And that's where you can move
from pilot to the next stage.
So what we focus on here
is the why and not the how.
Because many times, you start
off with the technology.
You're proving out POC,
whether the technology works.
And it starts off as a
very grassroots thing,
but you want to really try
to go down to the making
a business impact.
And that's how you're
going to move from a pilot
to the full scale.
So when we think about
business outcomes
and how you're going to
really start thinking about,
it all starts with digitization.
And what is really digitization?
It's really a lot of things
which are analog today,
they're your
physical blind spot.
These are things which
are not connected.
Or even if there is
data, they are in silos.
So what you really
want to do is you
want to connect these things--
customers, staff, processes--
in a unified manner,
in a unified system.
So now you have all this
data coming together
in a single platform.
And from here on,
now you can start
to analyze and start
creating these insights.
And this is your
big data analytics.
On your past data,
historical data,
you can start to see what
things were going on,
what was the process, how things
were happening in your business
environment.
But then you want to
also start to look at,
can you create
prediction models?
Can you use machine learning
and advanced artificial
intelligence to create
predictive models
for your business,
which is really
indicative of the key
performance indicators?
And then you want to use all
of this information, which
is the real time
information coming
from the business, the
past behavior, past data
and insights, the
predictive model, the what's
going to happen in the
future, to really start
to think about workflows.
And that's very important,
because there are workflows
happening today.
But they are not connected.
They are in isolation.
You want to think
about, how can I
take that process, which is in
physical form happening today,
can we make it more digitized?
Can we make it all
connected in a seamless way?
And that's where you can start
to start optimizing and get
benefit from IoT.
So when we look at
IoT ROI, so it really
comes down to that you
want to be measuring
ROI, Return on Investment.
So there is a direct
ROI, which is essentially
revenues and costs.
So you want to
increase your revenues.
Can you sell more?
Or can you reduce your cost?
Are there things you
can do to reduce it?
So that's direct.
And there are things
you can do using IoT
because, with IoT, you have
more data, more insights.
So you can enable
features, enable sales,
service enablement.
You can do improved pricing,
measured demand and elasticity.
You can also look at
the costs and can we
improve efficiencies,
uptime, reduce the risk,
and improve quality?
But then there are
other benefits of IoT
which you can expand to.
For example, marketing.
And this is where you want to
know your end users better.
Can you use the data to
understand their behavior?
If they are connected through
IoT, you actually can.
And you can then upsell
and cross-sell products.
And you can do personalization
based on that customer.
You can also build better
products because now you
understand the customers.
You understand their behaviors.
And in general, you have
a better relationship
with the customer.
They connect with you more.
You have a better brand.
On the engagement side-- so when
it comes to service delivery
especially, you want to have
that deep customer knowledge
of how they use their product.
Can we proactively
reach out to them?
Can we help them?
Can we make their
experience very delightful?
And also, with all the data
which is coming through,
you actually start to understand
a lot of opportunities
which were in your blind spot.
And you start to see how
can you use that data
to mine new businesses and
create new business outcomes
which were not possible before.
So let's go into a few examples
of our different verticals.
Hopefully, this will
resonate with you
and give you an
idea of how you want
to start to think about
different use cases in IoT.
So for example, manufacturing.
So if you think
about manufacturing,
what's really important?
I mean, the important thing in
manufacturing is productivity.
Factories are
operational 24 by 7.
Can we keep the uptime?
Can it be more efficient?
Can it be more safe?
Because many of
these manufacturing
heavy industries inherently
have challenges there,
because it's a live environment
and a very high temperature
and extreme environment there.
So you could use
predictive maintenance.
We'll talk about some
of that later on.
But essentially use artificial
intelligence and machine
learning to create predictive
models for your machines.
So now you have a
better understanding
of when these machines is going
to fail so you can take action
up front.
You can also understand
what are the factors which
are driving the failures
so you can work on that
and extend the life
of your machine.
So essentially, you're not
only improving the asset
utilization, but you're
reducing the downtime.
The second aspect of
manufacturing is the process.
There could be inventory supply
chain or different processes.
For example, in a car,
it goes through paint.
It goes through a
retrofitting, testing.
And you want to understand
how much time it's
taking between each process.
You want to optimize for that.
And if there is an inventory
which has excess piling up,
you want to reduce that.
So these are all
different processes
you can understand by using
IoT and getting real time
insight of what's going on.
And then not only
in the factory,
but also especially in
just-in-time manufacturing,
it goes beyond the factory.
It's also connected
to your vendors
and upstream and
downstream supply chains.
And you want to get a very
good sense of how the supply
chain is functioning.
Is there going to be any
shortages of components
that may impact your
production and also, maybe,
customer experience in terms
of delivery of these products?
And in general, you
want to understand
how your employees are doing,
how your machines are doing,
and can you improve
your productivity
and reduce your
failure rates and have
a high ROI for your customers?
There are many partners, like
SpringML, Relayr, Tellmeplus,
Clear Object.
These are different
partners which
are actually using Google
Cloud Platform to deliver that.
And clearly, if you have
use cases around that,
you can also reach out to us.
And we can help on that too.
Likewise, on oil and gas,
it's slightly different.
The same extreme use cases,
but here the business outcomes
are really around,
first of all, can I
get better resource mapping?
Can I understand where the
next set of oil is going to be?
Can I use machine
learning, and can I
use satellite image data
to get that understanding?
Also I want to
optimize the machines,
and their failure is important,
and where different assets are,
the trucks are,
the real machines.
And even employees
are your assets.
And this is where you want
to understand, are they safe?
Are they in a safe environment?
If there is going
to be a problem,
you want to predict that.
And if there is a problem,
you want to evacuate.
And the safety is
very important.
So these are the key use
cases in oil and gas.
There are partners like Cisco,
Losant, again, Relayr, FogHorn.
They operate within the
whole IoT architecture.
Some are more in Edge,
some are in Cloud.
But there are a lot of
partners Google has which
can help in these use cases.
Let's talk about logistics.
Primarily, when we say
smart transportation,
it's really about logistics.
And that could be a vertical
by itself, but it also feeds--
we talked about manufacturing.
And even in retail, it feeds
the rest of the industries,
as well.
And here, the asset tracking,
clearly-- like these trucks
need to be tracked.
So asset tracking is important.
But many times, there
is also the product
on those trucks,
which is important.
And you want to
understand, for example,
if it's a cold storage,
you want to understand how
the temperature conditions are.
If you're transporting
something which
needs to be maintained
at a certain temperature,
then the telematics
of these vehicles,
how fast they're going, are
they following the route,
did they deviate
from their route,
needs to be notified
in real time
so you can take action on that.
And then also, just
like any asset--
we talked about
predictive maintenance--
you want to understand
the predictions of when
these assets are going to fail.
Can we do something to
enhance their useful life?
What are the key failure
modes for these assets?
So let's talk about health care.
So we'll talk about health
care, and pharma, and medtech.
They're two slightly different,
but very similar use cases.
So health care, this is
about, for example, hospitals.
This is hospitals or
extended day cares where
you're dealing with patients.
And really, what the main goal
for a lot of these hospitals
and in the health care industry
is really to serve patients.
And the patient experience
is the most important thing.
Their health is the
most important thing.
So you're using IoT to, first
of all, A, measure the assets.
So there are lots of
assets, like where
the wheelchairs are, where the
beds are, where the IV pump is.
So when there is a
need for it, the nurses
don't have to go look for it.
And they can address the
patient as fast as possible.
Also what happens
is, because there's
so much unpredictability
around these assets,
you end up buying
more than you need.
And it increases your costs.
And these are
expensive equipment.
And you end up having a
lot more of inventory.
And that adds to
your cost, overall.
And then we know about
this connected health,
use cases around monitoring
of key vitals of the patients
while they are at the facility,
like mental health patients,
or infants, et
cetera, where you want
to make sure either they
don't leave the facility,
and the key vitals are there.
If they fall, you want to be
able to detect fall detection
and take appropriate action
as quickly as possible.
Then let's go into retail.
There are lots of
use cases in retail.
We're already familiar
with many of them.
And we can all
associate with it.
So one of the key ones,
especially for the business,
comes down to better
engagement with the customer.
Because for retail, the
experience in the store
is the most important thing.
And can you use
the technologies,
like beacons, cameras,
and geolocation
based notifications to
create these experiences,
and location based notifications
and marketing on-site.
You may want to also use
image detection and video
analysis to look at footfall.
Or you can use RFIDs
for that and understand
what parts of the store
are high traffic areas.
And can they be used to improve
your promotions and product
placement, and in general the
way you operate your business?
Automated checkouts are
also very important,
because it's part of
the customer experience.
And can you do more with
IoT with understanding
who the customer is,
what products they have,
what account is associated
with to really improve
that analysis?
And then there are
a lot of use cases,
not just around customer
experience, but also
the back store operations.
And a lot of that is about
the best customer experience,
but also about inventory.
Do you have the right
amount of inventory at hand?
Is there a lack of inventory?
Can you replenish
quickly so, when
customers come looking for
something, it doesn't run out?
And then can you also have
a better understanding
of how the products are
moving on your shelf?
What are the fast
mover products?
What are slow movers?
Can you optimize a
placement on the shelf?
Let's talk about
pharma and medtech.
So this is about
pharmaceutical companies
and medical technology
companies who
are in the business
of helping customers
from a medication standpoint.
And their main goal is to
ensure that the customers
or the patients are taking
medicines appropriately.
And it's not only good
for the customers,
but also good for the business
where they can improve
the adherence of the medicines.
That way, they can
improve their revenues.
But also having a better
patient engagement
not only improves their
brand, but it also
allows them to do
automated interventions.
So if a patient is
not taking medicines,
they can notify them.
Or if it's a connected
insulin meter where
you could measure
the insulin levels
and inject appropriate amount
of insulin to the patient,
that can be done
automatedly as well.
And then there's a
big part about pharma
and medical is that they spend a
lot of time in the FDA process,
in the regulatory process.
And they have to go through
these clinical trials, which
is very expensive.
And oftentimes, a lot
of these clinical trials
fail because they just don't
have enough sample points.
But with IoT, you can actually
improve and accelerate that.
Because now, you can start to
get a lot of the data live.
And that will improve
the way you go to market.
And you can launch
your products faster.
OK.
So let's talk about
Google Cloud IoT.
What do we mean by that?
So when we look at the
Google Cloud IoT Platform,
you want to think
from both devices
all the way to the Cloud.
So on the very extreme
is the devices.
And these are the devices,
which could be Edge device,
for example.
And we have a product
that we'll talk
about shortly is the
Cloud IoT Edge, which
allows you to do three things.
One is it allows you to
connect to the Google Cloud.
This is a product called
Edge IoT core, which does it
securely, and then makes
sure the connection is
strong and easy for you
to develop as a product.
And second is the Edge ML, which
is how can you do inference
on the device and machine
learning on the device
and create those outcomes
without relying on the cloud?
We do support Android Things.
This is a Google OS
for IoT devices, which
is hardened and
built specifically
for IoT for the best security.
But we also support
other operating systems,
like embedded OSes
and Linux OS as well.
And finally, these are the
CPUs or the processor units.
So there's CPU, or the
general purpose or MCUs
can be GPUs for advanced
machine learning capabilities.
And then we have a dedicated
product we just recently
launched called Edge TPU,
which is for machine learning
inferences on the chip itself.
And it's a hardware accelerator.
We'll talk about
it shortly, too.
And on the right side
is the Cloud IoT Core,
which is the entrance
point for all the IoT
data into the cloud.
And this is basically
your gateway
to inside the cloud for
the rest of the products.
It basically pumps all this data
into Cloud Pub/Sub, which is
essentially your message queue.
And from thereon, different
products within Cloud IoT
can actually take up this data.
For example, you can use
Cloud Functions to create
your own applications.
You can also use Cloud Data
Flow to do ETL operations
and transform this data
and store it, for example,
in BigQuery or BigTable.
And then use machine
learning to get this data
from these databases, create
machine learning models,
and then do either
inference on the cloud,
or you can send these
models back to the Edge ML
to create these inferences
at the Edge, as well.
And then you obviously have
the visualization layer
on top of that.
That's the last thing.
You could use Cloud
Data Lab, Data Studio,
or maybe build your own insights
on top of the Cloud platform
to create those
visualization charts
and reporting, et cetera.
So that sort of, hopefully,
gives you an idea.
We also have a
Google Maps platform,
which is also a Google
product, which allows you
to get better location updates.
And you can feed
that information back
into the Google Cloud
Platform to create,
for example, asset tracking
use cases on top of that.
So let's talk about
why Google Cloud IoT,
and what's so
differentiated about it?
So first of all,
Android Things, we
have a unified end-to-end
integration where seamlessly it
connects with Android
Things and other OS
and connects to the cloud.
So it makes the
development of the hardware
and IoT devices easy.
It's a global IoT service.
It's purely a serverless
service where you don't have
to maintain different hubs.
You simply spin up your devices.
You only care about device's
data coming through.
You don't have to
worry about scale.
And it has
intelligence built-in.
So it applies machine
learning and AI in the cloud.
It allows you to create IoT
which is not simply basic use
cases, for example,
temperature monitoring,
but also create prediction
models around temperature.
As I mentioned, it's
serverless by design.
And this is true, just
like BigQuery and many
of these products.
So it basically is a
global network backbone
and a front end
which is essentially
powering the billion-plus
user applications from Google.
And pretty much all
Google applications
are built on the
Google Cloud Platform.
And then using the
same network backbone--
so this is what is powering
the Google Cloud IoT.
And you can take the
advantage of that network
for your application and
can build applications
with the same level of
reliability and scale.
So let's talk about
Cloud IoT Edge.
So if you step back, there
is the Edge computing,
which is along back
when there was no Cloud.
It was all on-prem.
But there has been a lot
of advantages to the cloud.
And people have been really
migrating to the Cloud.
But there are some
use cases where
there is a little bit of
Edge which is still there.
And that's important
from various use cases.
For example, it
could be security.
It could be the fact is that
you don't want some data.
It's mostly part
of policy that you
don't want some part of your
data to leave on-premises
to the cloud.
So can you do
processing on the Edge?
There could be use cases,
like robotics, where
the latency is very important.
So you don't want the round
trip delay times to the cloud.
So you may want to take
certain actions quickly,
and hence, you want
to do Edge computing.
Likewise, for
predictive maintenance,
we talked about a use case about
machine learning inference.
You may actually be doing
Cloud learning, ML learning
in the cloud, but you maybe
want to do the inference
in the device itself.
Likewise, object recognition--
so here if you want to be
taking quick--
for example, it's a
manufacturing line,
and you want to be
testing for defects.
And in order for you to
have the maximum yield
and the high
throughput, you're going
to be doing the fast
object recognition.
And again, it's an inference
on-prem on the device itself,
and that's something
you want to do quickly.
Likewise, there are use cases--
if you're all familiar with
smart vehicles--
warehousing where
there are AGVs.
And here, also, you want to
be taking actions quickly.
Or maybe the WAN connectivity
is not that reliable,
and hence, you want
to do Edge computing.
So what is Cloud IoT Edge?
So as we talked about,
it extends the cloud data
processing down to the Edge.
It runs on Android Things
and other operating systems.
It connects to the cloud
using the Edge IoT core.
It stores, processes,
filters, derives intelligence.
And then you can run inferences
for the TensorFlow Lite models,
locally.
And it allows you to
do next-gen of machine
learning at the Edge.
And this is how it really works.
You would start with the
building and the training
of the ML model in the cloud.
You aggregate the data
coming from the devices.
You aggregate the data.
You use a machine learning
model to train it,
and then you send it back.
Essentially, what
you would do is
you would convert that machine
learning model from TensorFlow
to TensorFlow Lite.
And then you would compile
it for the given target.
If it is the GPU, or
general purpose CPU,
or if it is the Edge TPU,
which I will talk next,
you would want to compile
it for that platform.
And then you would install
it, essentially send it back
to the device.
And you will start to do
inference on the device itself.
So we talked about
Edge TPU several times.
So what really is it?
So it is a very tiny, high
performance, inference chip
set, which is not a
general purpose CPU.
It is custom built
for machine learning.
It can do fast iterations.
And it's the first phase is
to build for video and vision,
because these are very
high CPU-intensive.
And it can run concurrently
at 30-plus frames per second.
This allows you to create high
performance machine learning
at the edge, with the low power
consumption, lower footprint.
And also, because it works
seamlessly with the cloud,
it's an end-to-end
implementation, not isolated
where you have to put it
all together yourself.
So you basically use
Cloud IoT core and Google
Cloud for machine learning,
and send these machine
learning models back
to the Edge TPU.
And you can do inferences.
And we are going to
provide you with the tools
and capabilities, so it's
very easy to use and deploy.
We'll also be providing you with
the Edge TPU development kit.
It will be coming in shortly.
Essentially, it would
have an Edge TPU.
It would have an
associated CPU, as well.
It would have a secure element.
We'll talk about it shortly.
It'll all be
integrated on a system.
It's called SOM, a
System On Chip module,
which you could use to create
applications and develop
these application before you
go into the full production.
And this SOM would actually sit
on, for example, Raspberry Pi.
And so that way, you could
reuse the development boards
you already have in an
environment you have
and just put in this new
SOM, which is already secure.
It connects seamlessly
to the cloud.
It has security built-in.
And that will allow you
to improve and increase
your go-to-market.
We will also have a
USB connected Edge TPU.
These are the AIY boards which
you can connect to your laptop
or development environment.
And then you can do machine
learning on these, as well.
OK.
So let's talk about Cloud
IoT core and security.
So Cloud IoT core I mentioned
is the entrance point
for all the IoT data.
But what really is it?
So basically, there
are two parts to it.
And one is the protocol bridge.
That's the connectivity part.
And that's essentially your
connectivity through MQTT
and HTTPS protocols.
It does automatic load
balances, takes the data up
from the devices and
puts it into the Pub/Sub.
The second aspect to it is
this entire device shadow, this
[INAUDIBLE],, like
what those devices are
and how they are managed.
So essentially,
all these devices
are added into projects
and registries.
And for each device,
there is a device ID
and additional attributes which
are required for a connection--
so for example, with a
public key or a certificate.
And then there will be
additional metadata and state
information about the device,
its health, and business
attributes of these devices, but
also the telemetry data which
is coming through the devices.
For example, temperature,
humidity, motion,
and all these different sensors
which are on the devices
would be on that.
So one of the very important
things about these devices
and IoT in general is security.
And we formally, Google
has a very strong opinion
on security.
And we have been pushing
the boundaries on that.
So the basic idea is that we
use essentially asymmetric keys.
So private key is
built into the device.
And the public key of
that is in the cloud.
And the way it works is that
the device, it's over TLS,
but the way it works
is through JWT tokens.
So the device will
create a JWT token
and sign it using
the private key.
And this private key is
then sent over to the Cloud.
And that signature-- the
private key is not sent,
the signed JWT is
actually signed.
And the JWT signature is
verified by the cloud.
And that's how the
connection is established.
So there are problems with that.
One is that you have to make
sure that private key is
safe and secure.
And what you would
end up doing is,
and that's what we recommend,
is using secure element
from microchip or NXB, which
has a private key built into it
at the manufacturing time.
And then you use
this private key.
Obviously, you cannot
use a private directly,
so you would end up having
the public key equal.
And you get that from
the manufacturer.
And you would put that
public key onto the cloud.
And when the device boots
up, it does the same thing.
It does the JWT
creation, signs it,
and associates with the cloud.
Now, this is a very
cumbersome process
where you have to write a script
and have these public keys sent
to the Device Manager.
So what we have come up
with and tried to solve for
is with the Cloud
IoT Provisioning.
This is a new service which
basically allows you to manage
this entire process easily.
So to recap, really, there
are two problems, right?
So one is this key manager.
You have to secure these keys.
You have to transfer these
public keys from the SE vendor
to the OEM.
And then there is the
device management part of it
is that, OK, now you
have to make sure
that these public keys and
device IDs are preregistered
onto the cloud.
And the same device ID and
the target information,
which project ID and
registry ID needs
to be actually on the firmware.
So that means that you have
to pay a lot of attention.
It becomes a complex process.
So what we're
trying to do here is
we're working with silicon
vendors, select silicon vendors
to get these public keys
from them which are stored.
You will simply use Reel ID or
UDID, or additional information
for security sake.
To get those and
claim those devices,
you will simply easily
create your targets,
which is simply your
registries where you
want to put those devices in.
And when the device
wakes up, it simply
asks for where it needs
to go, and it goes there.
So this is exactly what's
happening in this slide.
As I said, it's the same exact
slide as the previous one,
but the part here is that there
is a cloud IoT Provisioning
service which gets the public
keys from the silicon vendors.
And it allows you to
claim them, and it
allows you to
identify these devices
and provide the
related configuration
and also provide information
where these devices need to go.
It adds the target on to the
Device Manager in the cloud.
And so when the
device wakes up it--
and all these devices
are very generic.
You don't have to worry
about these devices.
They are very generic devices.
They go and basically
say, OK, I'm
X, Y, Z. Where am
I supposed to go?
It gets the new config,
which tells it where to go.
And this config could be
as elaborate as you want.
It could be a new firmware.
It could be any things you
want this device to do.
And then it comes
back as a new device
and connects to Google Cloud.
And that's how it gets
authenticated and starts
serving.
So let me do a quick
demo of this service.
And this is available
for early access,
but let me give you
a quick snapshot.
For example, when I
log in as a customer,
I'm going to be looking
at a blank screen,
obviously, because there
are no elements I have made.
So I'm going to go in here.
In this use case
I'm using Reel IDs.
So I'm going to have a Reel ID.
Reels are essentially all the
secure elements are chips.
They have wound up on a tape.
And it's wound up in a reel.
And it's a package.
It's essentially the package ID.
So I'm going to just
put a package ID here,
and I'm going to just claim it.
So it's going to basically
go through these reels.
And these reels
now have shown up.
have been claimed,
but they have not been targeted.
So now, I'm going to be
targeting into a registry.
So I have a registry open here.
And you can see
this is all empty
right now, so I'm
going to be putting
these devices in this registry.
And there is a registry--
-1 is a registry
in this project ID.
And that's exactly what
I'm going to be doing here.
So I'm going to target it to
this particular test target
here.
And I'm going to assign it.
So essentially what
it's going to do
is move these devices from
this place to the registry.
So basically what
it's doing right now
is it's going through
these in the loop,
checking for these devices.
And these devices are
now actually moving
into the registry.
So when I'm going to
try to refresh here,
I should be able to see shortly.
The devices should show up.
But if you want to, this is
available as an early access.
And you can sign up
for this early access
by clicking onto this link here.
And then we will
get back to you.
We want to understand
your use cases, as well.
And then we'll provide
you an early access.
So hopefully, it would
have come up by now.
OK.
So now, these
devices have come up.
And you can see
all these devices
which were empty before.
And then it's very easy for
us to move from these devices.
And here, these devices
have been empty.
So next time you have a
next batch of devices,
you come in and do the
exact same process.
So you don't have to worry
about where the devices went.
These all devices
are very generic.
When they come up, they
get their configuration,
and then they connect.
With that, we're going
to end the session here.
This is going to
be our last slide.
And then stay tuned
for Q&A. And we'll be
right back in a few minutes--
maybe less than a minute.
And then we'll take up the
questions which you may have.
So feel free to give us any
questions, any feedback.
And then we'll be
right back with you.
Thank you.
OK.
Welcome back.
So it looks like we have
three questions here.
So let's get going
with the questions.
So first question is, in terms
of Cloud IoT Provisioning,
I don't have secure
element right now,
but plan to use it
in future products.
Can I still use this service?
Yes.
So clearly, we are trying to
solve for the secure element
use cases, but that doesn't
mean that's the only use
cases we wanted to solve for.
So as we go through
this process,
we will be solving for the
non-secure element use cases,
because there are
ways for you to create
public, private key pairs today.
And we want to be able
to solve for the part
where you're confident
about the private key,
but the public key still needs
to be connected, and put that
into the cloud repository.
And we want to make
that process easy.
So yes.
That's the short answer.
So let's see.
The next question
is, do I have to use
Edge TPU to take advantage
of Google's Edge processing?
OK.
So yeah, no.
I mean, clearly,
Edge TPU gives you
that advantage for
the use cases where
you need heavy processing.
But there are a lot
of Edge use cases
where maybe general purpose
CPUs is perfectly fine.
Because even on the
ML and AI, there's
a huge range of
computational requirements.
So no.
We wouldn't support GPUs or
support general purpose CPUs.
And whatever your model
is which you have created,
it can be used
through our products
to send back those models from
Cloud IoT to Cloud IoT Edge.
And then you can
use these models
for inference in the Edge.
And then, if you're
going to use TPU,
then we will support that too.
So Edge TPU's not the only
thing we're supporting here.
Next question we have
is, can we configure
Cloud IoT Edge,
plus Android Things,
plus Edge TPU on the currently
available Raspberry Pi?
Yes.
So as I mentioned,
it is a SOM, which
is essentially going to have
all these things in one SOM.
And yes, you could use the
Raspberry Pi with that SOM.
But when that SOM is
going to be available?
Sometime in the upcoming
months it will be available.
So you want to sign up
for that early access.
So let us know.
We want to work with you.
And so make sure that you are
one of the first customers.
But yes.
You could use any general
purpose Raspberry Pi.
And that's the whole
idea of that SOM.
It just goes on top of it.
And you can start off
with your projects
right now without the Edge TPU.
And then when that's
available, you
can make that Edge TPU capable.
OK.
Well, thanks for
all these questions.
And thanks for your time.
Stay tuned for the next session.
It's CE Chat, Google
Cloud Networking 102.
It's cloud routing
and VPC pairing.
Thank you again for your time.
And feel free to go
to the Cloud IoT core.
I mentioned there was this--
let me see-- go to
Cloud IoT core website.
You can sign up for the Cloud
IoT Provisioning early access.
And also, you can sign up for
the Edge TPU and Cloud IoT Edge
early access, as
well, on our website.
OK.
Well, thanks again.
And have a good day.
Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]